ainsi perdure la tradition d'éloigner
les ténèbres une nuit à la fois
le grand-père du garçon travaillait au
fin de Riverside et ce n'était pas un
phare comme les autres il éloignait la
menace des ténèbres d'un autre monde
il ne faut pas laisser le chasseur
atteindre les serres qui gagnent c'est
grâce à leur patte dans ce que la
rivière coule sans la rivière la vie
s'éteindrait heureusement c'est qu'une
légende
nous comptons tous sur toi pour
perpétuer ces traditions
mais on est où c'est un endroit magique
salut petit gars réveille-toi
réveille-toi réveille-toi tu es réveillé
[Musique]
je m'appelle Patrick je suis la
meilleure océros gigoter
ruines se cache nos peurs les plus
secrètes
vous êtes le chasseur je suis bien le
chasseur moi j'ai peur de rien arrête tu
as peur
[Musique]
ici tu sauras faire fuir les ténèbres
les rivières font le lien entre toutes
les choses et toutes les créatures nous
fabriquons de l'énergie en dansant en
leur honneur et nous leur rendons
ensuite
le arrivé je sais plus quel Lopez j'ai
pas l'habitude de faire du sport
celui-là il est pour toi grand-père
on va où on va bien se marrer tu vas me
dire